and sir if you remember what these stood
for work the mean is the average right
remember is the median is the little
squatter your how much is quasi just go
right down there and what's the mode
it's the one you have the boost off okay
now all three of these all three of
these are all different ways of getting
one thing which is they have a very big
fancy name which is they're all measures
as it ways to measure central tendency
that's a bit of a fancy way of saying if
I have a group of people right if I know
all their heights or I know all of their
ages or all of their income or whatever
right what's the center of the group one
one they all tend towards if I could
summarize the whole group in one Dunbar
where did that big okay and each of
these have their own attractive features
about them okay for instance with the
mean we giant we generally think that
like that's a normal way of working out
what they're all life but what's the
problem with the mean there's a big
problem with it
good remember there's a big problem with
yeah anything very good even got them
work master if you can't remember an
outlier up an outlier ears aren't yet
joined you wanna yeah that's right it's
like he's all he's a whole bunch of data
and you got a number it's really really
high or really really low literally it
lies outside the rest of the data when
you have an outlier the mean will get
thrown up or down okay so the median
will do a better job at getting that if
you have this kind of thing okay the
bird when you might use the mode the
mode being useful kind of thing to do
yeah
fantastic so if you're trying to
quantify something that's not numerical
like okay there's an election coming up
okay who's going to be the person
elected well you can't take an average
between you know the Prime Minister and
the opposition leader what's the average
between these two human beings you can't
do that what you can't do is say well
which one is the most votes right the
mood okay so they each had their measure
now there was one other number that we
realized was important it didn't start
with M range very good right so range
now range is not a measure of the center
of a group right what is it a measure of
yeah yeah fantastic the biggest number
take away this force so what it really
tells you is how spread out a group of
numbers are right so that's why we call
it in fact a measure off not central
tendency but spread or dispersion is the
fancy way of saying how are they
dispersed how they spread out okay now
range is the only one we look but just a
bit of teaser we won't cover it but I
just want to tell you one of these you
might have heard the phrase before
there's another really important
technical way of being able to say how
something is dispersed because if I give
you two sets of data on right which are
for instance I've got so he's like zero
to ten zero to ten okay if I've got a
class and they're scoring on a quiz
right if I have a class like this okay 1
or 0 1 or 10 what's the range of this
class it's just the biggest take away
the smallest so it's just 10 right so
y'all okay that tells me the ranger told
me how spread out but this class is very
very different from this class right
very very different classes do you agree
like that you would describe them as
different kinds of classes but they have
exactly the same range right so we have
more technical ways you'll start
learning about them next year in the
year after that in
ticular the one you learn about is
called in the future standard deviation
it's a big technical phrase deviation
literally means that going away from
something how far you spread out so
these two classes if you like would have
different standard deviations this
standard deviation will be very small
they've sort of clustered together
whereas this standard deviation be very
large okay the mean is somewhere in here
and everyone is very distant everyone's
dispersed out so we have these right
these are like the the actual summaries
right how we find them